[Music]
hey everybody welcome to every damn day
I am Ryan BEC that is Hannah Dickinson
Natasha vain bought in Jordan Mendoza
today we're going to be talking about
office romances because we all know the
office is a great place to have sex with
someone so what we're going to talk
about today office romances and
obviously we can use clips from the
office to punctuate our points so I have
four types of office romances that I
want to discuss today the first being
the most important the office fuck-buddy
you thought I might say true love or
something there's no Jim and Pam
horseshit this is Ryan and Kelly that's
what we have for you right now or GPA
cuz your name is also Ryan that's true
as well if I get to stay
Ryan is Lea Hough I will kill myself
like Rome Angelia the Claire Danes won
over although we still all have our job
so no no can't explain it what I like
about it is that he doesn't like her and
she likes him a lot
yeah are you have you ever been that
like crazy person or have been like
someone had a crazy person like totally
into you like you one time you hook up
with them this is the show where we talk
to each other just like no but like have
you ever been the crazy person or had a
crazy person into you because you guys
hook up one time maybe they're
attractive but thinking like oh no this
is person's nuts yeah actually one time
I had a guy threatened to murder me
choking me Oh in the moment yeah he said
I'm murder you did you work
together no Willie does comedy Oh
so you guys were having yeah we're
actually working some things out yeah
you only get three minutes you got to
get everything in there because I came
[Laughter]
the creepiest thing I can conjure is
once I went on a date with a guy
afterwards he made me like an animated
short film like that was like a story of
my life and so you didn't work out yeah
what did Jordan say when you told him
that you liked this film would ya what
do you think about all the After Effects
work I put into it yeah I thought it was
really realistic the way our children
looked was spot-on yeah yeah wait why
why didn't work out it then I was like
okay it got to be like a little too
creepy you know sorry I'm sorry about
that
professionally work together and then
you found a new love yep yep this this
being on this couch right now is very
hard for me especially with this arm
wrapped around so sexual Here I am all
alone in this chair uh have you ever
hooked up with anybody that you worked
with and want to talk about it right now
I have not hooked up with anyone that
I've worked in besides these two on the
couch right now and I have kissed that's
not like private knowledge that's public
knowledge everyone knows about that if
you're watching us you know about that
obviously don't we have footage of
remember you can watch the footage right
here
Bardolph I make notes really like so
hard or editors right here right here
[Laughter]
no I think it's a great place if you're
single you should meet people in the
office right so I got to go to work and
there's lots of attractive people are
interested in the same thing as me
yeah and I'm single and I just have to
ignore them yeah and then have the
energy to go out to a bar and meet
someone hoping that they have the same
interests as me
yeah no way yes no yes yes would
technically like if you consider comedy
the workplace I've dated a lot of
comedians so it's like yeah okay Jordan
we did not date okay did he make you a
movie no he didn't and that's why I'm
pissed off right now I'm working on it
it takes a long time to get the hair
just right so one of the other types of
office romances of course and maybe
you're not sleeping with them but they
are like your work wife or your work
buddy and that is what I would say
Dwight and Michael are make a right turn
wait wait wait no no no it means bear
right not there it said right it said
take a right no no no no look it means
go up to the right bear right over the
bridge and hook up with 3:07 baby it's a
shortcut Dwight did say go to the right
it can't mean that there's a light it
knows where it's going machine
the thing that I've liked so much about
doing our little talk show here is that
I think that we are now all in work-wife
work we are I'm entered in this
relationship with all of you well we all
just sit around our little table of our
jokes yep and then you know we all eat
lunch together and then after lunch we
all I would say you're my work wife
because you're always nag nag sorry that
I care doing like a work grandpa he like
sleeps up through lunch
where's corduroys everywhere just
leaving bowls of soup they're really
coming in in sweatpants they're just
practical guys and they're taking a nap
up for lunch that's a good thing that
means I'm energized for the rest of the
day do you have a work wife no I'm a
yeah I'm a one-man one-man band
I'm like a work distant aunt I feel like
I'm alone I've actually never gotten
through a full sentence with Natasha
outside of this room where her
headphones don't come in what are you
gonna do later are you gonna go to one
time and I had a show together after
work and I was like oh I'm gonna get a
cab if you wanna grab but she's like my
thing we're gonna walk I remember that
my favorite like distant aunt move that
Natasha makes is that you're booked an
entire conference room yes so we'll be a
place that is supposed to be for like 20
people and it'll just be her with her
headphones in computing computing okay
mostly just yeah data entry that's yeah
people are like banging on the door like
we need a meeting sorry reserved them's
the rules
let's go into the next clip right here
she's marrying me well I don't know
about that because she certainly seems
to enjoy making lovemaking with me
Angela Bernard will never be her name
will be her name you will have to call
her that I don't think so
hey guys why don't we just cool off a
bit
look Oh Stingo a love child I've had I
was once kicked out of a threesome
that's very obtuse I'm gonna get fired I
was in a love triangle at work before no
way for sure Wow wait at the news been
news in general I worked at the news and
there was this hot babe and we hit it
off but there was also a guy who also
thought she was a hot babe and everybody
wanted her little attention and I'm
trying to be cutesy here everybody
wanted her attention because she was
very cool and she was smoking hot and
eventually we know I won out by like
just being myself and be like ignoring
like you know hit this guy was like
always in her business whenever else and
I was just like very cool and sat on the
other side of the room so so she was in
her business and you watched from the
other side of the room
no I was the sounding board yeah I can't
believe no that's so hard for you I was
cool is what I'm trying to sister okay
well you guys hooked up oh yeah it's
pretty cool that's awesome
which one what are the bases yeah what a
second base boots what a second base in
your world this is what I want to scale
[Laughter]
she's over here you talking about that's
a real love triangle
there was a triangle there was like does
the gut did that guy end up hooking up
with her now
no okay Wow but you did yeah I'm pretty
cool people find me attractive which
brings this which brings us to our last
office romance true love something we
don't have here did you want to tell me
something you look like you want to tell
me something you look like you have
something really important to say you
just can't for some reason come on you
can tell me
Jim you can tell me anything
there you go Jim and Pam the obvious not
the lamest characters on the show Jim
and Pam it's like very gets false hope
no people get together at offices like
that that is such
there were people so I did briefly teach
at a school that is now shut down so
it's like no more and there were two
people teachers who fell in love at that
school and at their wedding their
wedding song was we fell in love in a
hopeless my JV soccer coach ended up
getting married to a girl that he had
coached like six years prior and
everybody was like not talking about it
and I did not make varsity because I was
talking about it I was like this is
what's going on here that doesn't seem
right no like very very small my Spanish
teacher in high school got arrested
mid-year for soliciting sex with a minor
no and he no boys crazy as he had been
voted Teacher of the Year five years in
a row so he was like everyone's favorite
yeah it turns out he loved us all - yeah
I think I said no boy no earlier this is
sexual crime and it always does thanks
for watching this has been every damn
day make sure to check us out on Twitter
Monday through Thursday on extra damn
day thanks for watching
[Music]
you